Một khi trên đấu bỏ vệ tụ quốc, ông bớm vụ lên lượt có bẩy cơn gái, ai cũng sinh đẹp và giảm dân
và tụi buổi người được hợp trái ngọt.
Đó là hình cạnh của gia đình ông bỏ các lương, sáng miếng sáng tụi, người an và bà lưu thế lựu, sáng miếng bà tụi.
Ông lưng bị mù năm 2020 trong thời gian thang gia sìm đấu bỏ vệ tụ quốc,
tương mô tên nghiênh có ngoại hình caul lưỡn, ông trở về quế hơi với thương tật và những tranh trở cho tương lai.
Dù ông tương tật, bà lưu vẫn đồng ý cả trở ông, dù lần lựu sinh ra bởi của con gái xinh đẹp,
và nguồn, lúc bỏ xinh bà con gái đầu, ông nhất quyết không cho vự xinh đữa,
tuy nhiên, bà thương ông là con trường, mắt lệ mù, nguyên cầu kiếm con trái.
Cả hãy ông bà có trung quan điểm, dù vất vả cũng phải nguyên con anh học ấy nơi đến chốn,
như vậy, mời cố con gái điều học hết caul đảm và đại học.
Sơ bao năm là lụng nguyên con ông bà không tích cóm cho tụi ra,
mấy thấy mời trảy ngọt ông bà dầu trong vô của vụ giữa thậm không chỉ việc bố mẹ lên dừng dũng biển dù ngoạn,
mời cô con gái cộng có tìm để làm nha mối khăn trang cho ông bà anh hưởng tuy ra.
Chá tối lưu tình tưởng, lắng nghe, thủ hiểm bất tự hào viết các con.
Nhất là chá chết tưởng thấy không có con trái là mất thịt.
Chá tối mù, sống trong bong tối như mại xơi đường cho ra đến gần bất cứu anh cạnh nào.
Một người con của ông Lưu Chia Xe.